Sarah hooker is an exceptionally
talented and accomplished leader and
research scientist in the field of
machine learning she's the founder of
cohere for AI a non-profit research lab
which seeks to solve complex machine
learning problems she's passionate about
creating more points of entry into
machine learning research and has
dedicated her efforts to understanding
how progress in this field can be
translated into reliable and accessible
machine learning in the real world
Sarah is also the co-founder of the
trustworthy machine learning initiative
which is a forum and seminar series
related to trustworthy ml she's on The
Advisory Board of patterns and is an
active member of the mlc research Group
which has a focus on making
participation in machine learning
research more accessible
before starting cohere for AI Sarah
worked as a research scientist at Google
brain she's written several influential
research papers including the hardware
Lottery the low resource double blind an
empirical study for pruning for low
resource machine translation and moving
beyond algorithmic bias is a data
problem and also characterizing and
mitigating bias in compact models in
addition to her research work Sarah is
also the founder of the local Bay Area
non-profit Delta analytics which works
with non-profits and communities all
over the world to build technical
capacity and Empower others to use data
she regularly gives tutorials on machine
learning fundamentals interpretability
model compression and deep neural
networks and she's dedicated to
collaborating with independent
researchers around the world
so we just mentioned the hardware
Lottery above Sarah is famous for
introducing this concept of the hardware
lottery in which the success of a
research idea is determined not by its
inherent superiority but by its
compatibility with available hardware
and software she argued that choices
about hardware and software have had a
substantial impact in deciding the
outcomes of early computer science
history and that with increasing
heterogeneity of the hardware landscape
gains from advances in Computing may
become increasingly disparate
Sarah proposed that an interim goal
should be to create better feedback
mechanisms for researchers to understand
how their algorithms interact with the
hardware they use she suggested that
domain-specific languages
auto-tuning of algorithmic parameters
and better profiling tools may help
alleviate the issue as well as providing
researchers with more informed opinions
about hardware and software and how it
should progress
ultimately Sarah encouraged researchers
to be mindful of the implications of the
hardware Lottery as it could mean that
progress on some research directions is
further obstructed anyway if you want to
learn more about that paper in
particular watch our previous interview
with Sarah it was really really good so
anyway without any further delay I give
you Sarah hooker so I'm here in London
in coher's offices with the one and only
Sarah hooker Sarah it's lovely to see
you in person it is so nice to finally
meet you in person it feels long overdue
I know I know so I think about 18 months
ago we did an interview on your Hardware
Lottery paper which you're very very
famous for it's one of my favorite
episodes we ever did we ever did it's a
fascinating paper and I see that pattern
of thinking almost everywhere every day
so um so that's amazing but um anyway
you've done loads and loads of work in
In fairness and interpretability in
particular and we'll explore some of
that today but um tell me about the
state of fairness at the moment
I think that the state of fairness is uh
in my mind there's three main things
that fairness researchers need to
Grapple with that are almost big hurdles
right now so one is that we tend to
treat fairness as like a static snapshot
in time but in fact like one of the key
changes and how we think about fairness
is this motion over time this like drift
and so a lot of the things that we think
about In fairness may actually change a
lot in the future uh like think about a
comedy show that you watched 10 years
ago and thought was funny that no longer
is funny today so there needs to be in
many ways a treatment of fairness is
like adapting to distribution shifts
over time I think the Second Challenge
is we tend to rely a lot on labeled
prospectus of fairness so we assume that
we already know what we're worried about
and we already have comprehensive labels
the truth is in most problems we
actually don't know so how do we audit
large data sets but also we rarely have
comprehensive labels and this means that
sometimes when we treat things as
assuming that it's very toy very it's
almost like treating like a toy problem
I think a third is very actually core to
machine learning in general which is
that different uh cultures have
different Notions of fairness and so
there's almost this distribution shift
again in terms of geography but that's
also very core to fundamental machine
learning problems of how do we adapt our
models to very different Downstream
tasks and different distributions and
perceptions of what is fair and how do
we want our models to behave okay really
interesting so so the first one is
machine learning models they take a
snapshot in time yeah and you know
things change values change over time
I'm really interested in this concept of
you said that the labels because in a
way it's a form of reductionism you know
we try to understand things and we have
this anthropocentric way of reducing
things which are intelligible to us and
as soon as we reduce things down to a
class label we in you know we confer
lots of bias uh in in the process so how
do we wrestle with that
yeah I mean that's one part of it which
is to even attach a label of what we say
is toxic we may have different Notions
of what we think for example is toxicity
and we may be calibrated differently and
we see this all the time so there's
annotated bias there's also High
annotated variants and a lot of these
Concepts like toxicity like very uh
sensitive Notions like the labeling in
someone's race there's a second issue
though which is that even if we assume
that we as humans are perfect at
determining what is toxic
it's really expensive to get human
annotations uncomprehensive these are
the type of labels where most of the
world is unsupervised and we now have
these massive data sets which are
largely crawled from really the web that
don't have comprehensive labels and so
that's almost a second hurdle even
assuming we were perfectly calibrated
the assumption that that data exists is
already it's almost we've we've already
failed because we're not really
developing techniques for the real world
which is those labels don't exist
fascinating I've spoken with some people
recently about how to define
intelligence and Consciousness and
causality and it's they're all complex
phenomena is fairness complex in the
same way
I think that it's complex in the the
sense that we
when we talk about fairness we often are
talking about
uh a set of preferences about how a
model should behave and often we're
talking about constraining Model
Behavior so often the task is maybe a
model was trained on data that has all
these historical biases and now we want
to constrain it so it's not
representative of the data was trained
on with things like Consciousness I
often think we're trying to emulate a
certain type of intelligence it's often
very framed in terms of our human
perspective so we're not necessarily
trying to constrain Model Behavior the
same way but we are trying to develop
models that are able to navigate the
world in a robust way
the conflation with Consciousness I
always find to be
it tends to become quite muddled quite
quickly I don't know what's the best
answer you've seen to this question I've
done so many interviews on it recently
and they're honestly very muddled right
it goes into philosophy very very
quickly yeah I mean you can speak about
Nagel's bats and
um you know Chomsky talks about the the
limits of our cognition so it's
impossible for us to understand it
Chalmers thinks that it's just a magical
extra on top of function behavior and
Dynamics
um so it's not even an intrinsic part of
the system I mean it's it's very very
confusing but so many topics and they I
do do go to go to philosophy very very
quickly but um okay this is really
interesting so one thing that I really
like the idea of is um remember Jan
McCune made a tweet saying oh it's all
data bias and you've been one of the
biggest proponents of convincing people
that there's loads and loads of model
bias remember that paper where you spoke
about on the long tail or the low
frequency attributes those are the
um those are the the data points that
get pruned very very quickly so um yeah
just and I know you had a paper about
that as well but can you can you sketch
out why model bias is so important yeah
and really good memory
that's amazing um no a lot of uh a lot
of what's interesting about this
perspective that's both model and data
is that we're in this regime of ever
increasing size and models and what's
interesting about it is that with larger
models comes a bigger propensity to
memorize and what does that mean for a
lot of fairness Concepts we're talking
about fairness Concepts where we weren't
either to represent long tail low
frequency at attributes especially if
that low frequency attribute is
protected or in other instances we want
to curb that memorization and so
depending on your notion of fairness
often when you increase the size of the
model you gain this better
representation of the long tail which
can also lead to better outcomes for
this low low frequency subgroup
and that's why these things are very
interrelated
the majority of the field has focused on
data but the same way that remedies like
data augmentation can help in
representation so can thinking about the
optimization choices your model and it's
not just model size it's things like do
you use gradient clipping so in a
privacy setting so if you're using
gradient clipping that's a strategy for
mitigating
privacy leakages because what it does is
it curbs performance on the low
frequency attributes so the model is not
really able to memorize the long tail
but that also can lead to fairness
trade-offs where essentially by Curbing
and Grading clipping or noise injection
your eroding performance on that
underrepresented subgroup amazing okay
great so there's there's this concept of
the tyranny of objectives and when you
optimize for one thing it's like the
shortcut rule it's at the expense of
everything else and we optimize for
headline metrics such as accuracy so
there are lots of trade-offs and and
also we can talk about this General
theme in interpretability recently which
you know when I started learning about
it it was sharp and shapley values and
lime and all of these post-hoc
interpretability techniques and now what
I'm reading is that there's a huge focus
on actually kind of training the model
with fairness objectives in mind which
is a completely different way of
thinking about it so can you sketch that
up
so what you're really talking about is
kind of this progression of where a lot
of research focus is centered if you
think about post-talk methods it's
almost like uh you are at the Finish
Line you have a model and then you're
trying to do acrobatics to explain the
logic also one key difference in the
methods that you really are referring to
are these are often single example
explanations they're very focused on for
this prediction or for this generation
why did the model do it in this way uh
it it's interesting because in some ways
like by the time you get to the Finish
Line you're so baked in to the
constraints of the model you haven't
optimized at all for interpretability
yet you're just hoping that you can do
acrobatics at the end and make it
interpretable
I think what's a really interesting
direction is what you're talking about
whereas can we explicitly optimize for
uh the objectives that we care about or
uh can we essentially look at even for
the case of interpretability can we look
at how features emerge over the course
of training because that can give you
really strong signal about how a model
learns the decision boundary over time
so that's often at the overall data set
scale so it's not as centered in the
single predictions but in some ways it's
very useful because
there are different interpretability use
cases one is always going to be the
single prediction but for someone who's
deploying a model or someone who's
auditing overall Model Behavior it's
very difficult to know what to do with
millions and millions of single
prediction explanations in some ways you
kind of want to know the relative what
does the model do really poorly at what
does it do well at and how can I
understand the perception of this
distribution and behavior on the
distribution okay okay so yeah the
um having model based and white box
approaches are really important now I'm
speaking to Randall balestria and he's a
big advocate of the spline theory of
neural networks which I love and that's
this idea I mean you can actually use it
as a visualization device so it's this
idea that in an input sensitive way that
an MLP will kind of subdivide the
ambient space up into all of these
affine linear polyhedra and it's really
good from an interpretability point of
view because you can actually see where
the areas of of you know the training
support and the data density is the
polyhedra are smaller and much closer
together and you've always said before
that the challenging and you know
difficult or the low frequency
attributes tend to be very close to the
decision boundary so like having this
kind of model-based way of understanding
as you say during training and and at
the end of training how the models
behave is is really important right
I yeah I completely agree this is a very
interesting problem for a few reasons so
firstly looking at
relative difficulty tends to be very
interesting because uh in some ways like
these are the areas where the decision
boundary is less firm it's interesting
for a few reasons one is just auditing
safety issues but the other really
interesting direction is that we're in a
scale of bigger and bigger data sets but
the relationship with uh how that
impacts model quality is less and less
certain what I mean by that is that we
now have recent Works which show that
you can go smaller and higher quality
and Achieve as much performance with
with needing less capacity on the model
side so ascertaining what are your hard
examples and then modifying how you're
using capacity so you don't have to
treat all these examples equally which
is what we do now we essentially pass
through all examples the same amount of
time it can be really interesting in
terms of adaptive computation and that's
why methods which ascertain relative
difficulty but also get a sense of the
distribution and spend more time on
certain parts of distribution are really
compelling and it's an area of research
which I think is timely like it is uh it
is answering this question of do we need
as many parameters if we can more about
the data space and we really first we
refine our subset selection and can that
guide using uh more efficient models
yeah absolutely what would you say to
the current culture of Sota chasing and
you know I think it's fair to say that
people aren't acknowledging enough the
importance of having models that reflect
our values as they change over time
um oh yeah that's a fun question that's
that's a bit of a yeah I mean sort of
chasing so I think there's almost like
what do I think about soda chasing
there's also the current formula for
winning instead of chasing so right now
the formula is very simple you throw
more parameters of the problem more data
it's a very hard argument to to to
or very hard recipe to argue against
because it's so convincing so it is
shown clear progress and many tasks so I
definitely think some people should work
on it but it's not the heart of the
problem in my mind mainly because we're
having to throw in so much more data and
so many more parameters to show gains
and so there's clear this question of
how do we do this much more efficiently
and I think most people should be
working on that question of really
thinking through uh
why we have to essentially extend Nano
access here in terms of monocytes so
much to make increasing gains
um there's then this question of which I
think is a little bit separate of uh how
do the models reflect our values and how
do they navigate the world I think that
it's interesting I I don't think that
soda is necessarily the problem with
models that reflecting our values soda
is just extending this one axis of how
we Benchmark right uh but the the big
problem is rather
we don't really have uniform values as
uh you know a world as you know groups
of humans and so I actually think this
question of reflecting values is very
intrinsic to the question of
generalization like how can you adapt
models to really reflect uh different
distributions and different beliefs and
that's really whenever people talk about
the notion of fairness for me it's
always been intrinsic to this question
of uh really adaptive models to and
creating models which are Dynamic enough
to navigate the world even when you have
changes over time because one of the
things we often mistake when we talk
about Fitness is this idea that's static
in form when it's really not at all yeah
um reinforcement learning might be an
interesting way to think about this
because you have run one reward function
is that reward is enough paper it's
quite interesting but
um but also with people that speak about
utilitarianism there's one utility
function tends to get very complicated
very good quickly and when we have an
intelligible framework of what values
are and they might be different
depending on where you're around the
world you get to the situation where
you're kind of optimizing on many things
at the same time and that doesn't really
lend itself to machine learning very
easily like how would you approach that
problem
yeah
um
I feel like so there's a few steps there
so one is
enforcement learning work for this so I
think I just mean that's an example of
we're optimizing for a single reward so
it doesn't it doesn't have to be
reinforcement oh so is the question
would a single word ever work for this
type of uh yeah because I think it's
even if you're building an image
classifier there's one objective
function and it kind of feels like well
if you care about this type of fairness
and this type of fairness what do you do
do you take a parameterized convex
combination of two and you create one
reward function
so one which I find really interesting
is just having uh adaptive development
sense so let's say you care about
toxicity and you have one notion of
toxicity in the U.S another notion and
somewhere else and maybe these don't
align these annotator groups don't align
right now a solution is to annotate a
lot of data and so we need those for
development sets so then constrain
optimization I'm much more interested in
supervised methods which can find
similar instances and kind of adapt over
time so take some no show ground truth
but adapt it over time to really
dynamically adjust the development set
and I think that's one way where you can
still have a single optimization
criteria but in some ways you're really
changing what you're optimizing over
these problems are very related to the
question of continual learning or to
really iterative learning so this idea
that over time you're going to
experience new tests and you somehow
need to still have the same overall
objective but you'll you have to adapt
to new data and not be derailed by it so
these are very related questions in a
way interesting so on on self-supervised
learning Randall had a paper on that at
Europe's where he was um looking at
different non-contrastive losses and the
way that he compared them was actually
by you know cheating and reintroducing
the labels and putting them in an
adjacency Matrix and um I guess what I'm
saying is is that self-supervised
learning probably produces better
representations and you're not kind of
focusing you know these brittle
um class labels into the training
process but it feels like by the same
token what we end up with is is less
intelligible yeah this is actually a
very important question so you've kind
of pointed out two things which we're
slowly realizing about the difference
between self-supervised and fully
supervised firstly self-supervised
doesn't have doesn't introduce the same
memorization abilities which means that
it struggles to learn the long tail
which can help with robustness right
because if we're not overfitting to very
very small differences then it's harder
to find a perturbation that is you know
non-trivial but still manages to distort
Behavior but it also means it fails to
learn the long tail so it fails that
some of this really uh great inductive
behavior that we see where for example
you have good representation on rare
instances and this is attention so I I
actually think this is relatively
underexplored and it's uh by Caribbean
overall model performance sometimes we
have these good inductive biases which
can make it more robust
I think the question there is is this
the measure of robustness that we care
about ultimately because that that for
me is one of the most timely questions
for that subfield is that right now if
you talk about robustness it means
totally different things to totally
different people and the measures of
progress are totally different so with
self-supervised learning
um I think that it's good that it's
robust but I'm not convinced that the
measures of robustness are meaningful
like the the whole elpino robustness is
less convincing to me image Corruptions
are more interesting but also uh for me
it's it's not clear what it's saying
because it feels like a lot of the
mitigation strategies in particular are
to solve for one type of robustness and
then you still have this issue with uh
You're vulnerable to other measures of
adversarial or sensitivity to robust
factors amazing okay we'll get into Data
augmentation in a minute when we speak
about your paper but
um I was trying to find your paper with
Randall balestriero who he was telling
me that one of the approaches that used
to solve this was by having an ensemble
method with like slightly different um
you know objectives I think on a
different model could you introduce that
paper I'm happy to so that's a paper
that we'll be releasing early next year
uh it's a paper which looks at a very
specific uh mitigation strategy so
ensembling is very popular because it
provides gains overall and performance
but the gains quickly Plateau so
typically you can add like five six
ensembles then you see the performance
plateauing what we find is very
interesting and uh fascinating which is
that the games on your worst case error
do not Plateau so where ensembling is
really helping is in your low frequency
attributes what's even more fascinating
is that this can come from just a very
simple Ensemble so all your varying is
the stochastic measures of training so
it's your initialization but nothing
else very simple it's a uniform Ensemble
and even then you see these market gains
on your worst case errors this is a very
simple strategy but it's really showing
that where ensembling and basically
pulling the wisdom over areas of
disagreement really helps is on these
harder examples to begin with and that
can have these pronounced effects that
are very cheap but it can produce these
uh really improved fairness outcomes
amazing now we get these long tails
everywhere I worked on the Bing team for
a while and they had the concept of
headqueries and tail queries does it
make sense to think of the long tail as
a monolithic thing
no uh and I this is one of the hard
things about just thinking about the
long tail as atypical or unusual
examples because I think the hard thing
is right now
when we talk about probabilities or any
type of estimate of uncertainty you can
have high uncertainty examples that are
challenging but you can also have high
uncertainty examples that are complete
junk and that's why a lot of our
mitigation strategies which are to just
augment the long tail or to just upweigh
the long tail in some way don't end up
working because if your data set is
mainly junk then what you're doing is
you're just regularizing your model more
and it's really interesting because
right now we don't have tools to discern
between the two a lot of model signals
so you know going back to the paper that
you mentioned where you have harder
examples close to the decision boundary
part of the difficulty is that you can
have hard examples that are challenging
because it's atypical and you can have
hard examples that are challenging
because they're junk and both have
similar characteristics so if one area
that I think is very useful for this is
the key distinction between noisy and
atypical is the learnability so noise
the whole definition is that it's
irreducible Error and so you should not
see a pronounced change in the rate of
learning and this is an area in which I
think we need much more work which is to
ascertain the difference between the two
you because the mitigation strategies
are so different for noisy you want to
throw it away very typical you typically
want to up weight you want to really
emphasize those of you a subset your
core difficult examples that you want to
spend more time learning so this is a
very fun area and it's a area that
hasn't had enough attention
yeah this I'm trying to think of a name
for this because you're talking about a
new regime of controlling the algorithm
during training would you call that
um Interactive Learning I think Randall
called it what was the term he used so
uh Interactive Learning is one I also
just think of it as adaptive computation
one of the core limitations of our
current model is that we treat all
examples uniformly and we we show all
examples the same amount of time but I
think that there's uh really room for
just much more focus on adaptive
computation that also distinguishes
between these two because adaptive
computation right now is often thought
of as active learning and it's within
the lens of just the atypical or yeah
and noise is often thought of through
the lens of just subset selection just
remove the noise but in fact to do
things well you need to discern between
the two and you have to have active
learning for your hard examples but you
need to remove your noisy examples
progressively yes yeah I completely
agree with you I think folks that do
Active Learning it's still a very
monolithic um approach but this this
takes us perfectly to um the paper that
you wrote recently with Danielle D'Souza
A Tale of Two long tails
um you examine the efficacy of targeted
interventions for machine learning
models such as data augmentation to
reduce uncertainty and the results
suggested that interventions can
differentiate between different sources
of uncertainty and you just said noisy
or atypical examples and can be an
effective way to improve model
performance so um first of all can you
give us the elevator pitch but can you
also Define epistemic and alloteric
uncertainty yeah so really it's the
difference between reducible and
irreducible error yeah so when you have
irreducible error it's almost uh your
your the idea that you give more data or
that you add more capacity it's not as
if these examples are learnable because
essentially it's a stochastic mapping uh
and in the case of a supervised problem
but it's also just a stochastic input
you can imagine it as like a a scrambled
sentence in the case of a unsupervised
problem and what's hard about a reduced
swear is that in many ways when you add
more capacity you're just you're just
regularizing you're you're memorizing
junk but uh you're it's almost like a
regularizer it's why you need so much
more capacity I think it's one of the
main reasons why we see meaning such
large models to learn web crawl data
sets because we have so much junk in web
core data sets and they're so huge and
in order to get a good performance we
end up having to regularize and use all
this extra capacity reducible error is
different it's learnable and so with
more examples or more capacity you
expect to see an improvement in
performance
what that means in the case of
distinguishing between the two is that
that paper and Daniel was the first
author was really saying let's exploit
this difference in rate of learnability
to distinguish between the two and so
the intervention can happen and so you
can treat the two groups separately
more recently I've been exploring this
in the sense of how do we audit
large-scale data sets can we use signal
over time to discern between these
different types it's not necessarily
differences in learnability rate but
maybe difference in loss profiles
overall if you have something that you
codify as ground Truth junk or you know
irreducible and you have something that
you codify as like learnable
what can you do with by by knowing those
Footprints and seeing which are closest
to it in the training set yeah it's so
cool because we we spoke about exactly
the same thing last time and it's really
interesting to see how your thinking has
developed since then because we were
saying that there's there's this long
tail and the problem is how do you
distinguish between the junk and the
stuff that you actually want to focus on
and and this this method is actually a
very very interesting way of doing that
um okay so just just to make it a bit
more contract uh concrete I think you
did give me an example of an atypical
dataset you're talking about common
cruel but I mean can you think of
another one
so common core is interesting because it
actually has both you can think of so
within common cruel you have a lot of
junk from the internet like HTML code
um or you have a Reddit uh like you know
kind of gibberish like that are
nonsensical so often these are removed
right now using these rule-based
approaches so for example you'll remove
HTML code you'll remove things which
have too many punctuation marks because
that's taken as a sign of junk you also
have atypical you can think of a typical
in that scenario as you might have
non-english and so it's atypical but
it's got structural Integrity like it's
meaningful it's semantically meaningful
it's just not in the majority language
of your entire Corpus and so that's a
good example within that of this you
know reducible versus irreducible
because if you added more of that
language the model would learn an
appropriate structure it's just that
it's such a fraction of the overall data
set
cool amazing right so
um you also wrote a paper when less is
more simplifying inputs Aid neural
network understanding I think you were
the primary author but that was when
you're at brain earlier in the year yep
and um you investigated the effect of
simplifying inputs on neural network
image classifiers and the implications
this has for understanding the learning
process can you give me the elevator
pitch so Robin is the first Earth on
that paper and it was a really nice uh
collaboration that goes back to what we
were talking about before which is okay
doing all this acrobatics after training
is not the best way to arrive at
interpretability because it's almost
like we're shocked that the models are
interpretable when in fact we never
optimize for it this paper does the
opposite it says let's optimize
explicitly for this by making it part of
the process to distill what is important
what are the important bits within the
image that are important for end
performance what's nice about this is
that you're being explicit about your
objective but it's also providing a
degree of interpretability about what is
the Salient information across the
entire data set because it's a global
objective so one of the nicest set of
experiments that I really like is that
we added redundant information to a lot
of these data sets so for example we
would add stripes to the data set and we
would say we would preserve the original
labels and so then the goal was can you
does the simple bits learn to remove the
stripes and this was really nice because
in some ways we've crafted the ground
truth and we're showing that simple bits
actually does remove the Redundant
information
it's also getting to the heart of what
does the model actually need to perform
well because what this is really showing
in these scenarios it's showing that uh
you're learning what the model actually
leverages for its decision boundary
rather than trying to alter or
understand or arrive at it after
optimization when we no longer have some
guiding constraint yeah fascinating
um what approach did you use to measure
you know the the Simplicity of the
inputs and how did you what objective
did you use on the model yeah so for for
actually measuring the Simplicity we
just use bits so it was like we it was
generated using just a simple generative
model like as and That Was Then used to
guide the optimization process so we're
trying to minimize the number of bits
while still preserving the end accuracy
on the task the ritual task
fascinating okay and um what kind you
said you created an artificial test bed
yeah yeah
and that was just a series of tests but
we have some notion of what's redundant
so you can imagine one example is we
concatenated two data sets together but
preserve the labels of one of the data
sets and so then uh the the a good
simple bits algorithm would remove the
other data set that's not actually
related to the label so that's what we
see happening which is really nice
because it's a good way of uh often with
interpretability problems the hard part
of evaluation is not establishing you
don't have ground truth otherwise you
wouldn't need the interpretability
method in the first place and so what's
nice about this is what kind of crafting
a testing bed to make sure that our
method is being reliable oh cool and
what impact would it have on the
performance
it's a it's a frontier so it's kind of
fun because this is what I also like
about this approach is that you're being
explicit about the trade-offs whereas
often when we optimize for like a
saliency map or individual explanation
afterwards you end up perturbing the
input but you're not actually being
explicit about how it would have
impacted the classifier whereas here you
are you're making a part of the
authorization process and the truth is
that a certain amount of bits we see
pronounced degradation but for uh for
really a range that's uh in between I
think it depend on the data set but you
would see this nice uh kind of stability
where you wouldn't see as pronounced
trade-offs and I think that's part of
equipping practitioners we're figuring
out where do you see this erosion
because ideally you distill what's the
most important feature is while
preserving the same amount of
performance amazing amazing okay so um
what else have you been looking into
one of the biggest questions I'm
interested in right now is how do you do
efficient subset selection on large data
sets so so many of the techniques we
have for selection are very expensive so
you talked about influence functions
that's an example of a very uh or
memorization scores those are very
expensive techniques we need to mean
that scales and why this is interesting
is that one of my hypotheses is that we
can get away with much smaller models if
we care more about the data space and
scoring the quality of data another area
is really we have our research community
so we have both the full-time research
lab as well as the research community
and just structuring more problems where
we can really help support the creation
of resources for underserved problems
like multilingual data set
representation and also decentralized
training I find really interesting can
we have pools of researchers that can
have trusted devices
and have this really interesting
collection of resources and what types
of Hardware like if you had a
heterogeneous Hardware landscape uh what
type of chaos does that cause exactly
exactly okay wonderful now um I've been
using large language models a lot
recently everyone's talking about it
after chat GPT and we're here in coher's
offices so language models are the the
modus operandi so to speak
um what are your kind of high level
thoughts about what's going on with
language models at the moment
a lot of what we're seeing is an
increased focus on annotation so I think
what we've seen so far is that you can
get big leaps in performance by doing
web crawl data sets but the real gains
are coming from being very selective and
careful about your fine tuning stage and
particular like instruct style prompts I
think there's a few open questions there
so one is the transferability of
instruct style prompts from one
architecture to another but another is
how do you curate this in a meaningful
way and also what types of behaviors can
you induce based upon the data sets that
you collect
another interesting Direction I think is
increasingly
we have these large language models but
right now uh there's very few places
which can actually make them accessible
so I think there's a lot of questions
around efficiency and how do you
actually deploy large language models at
scale
um and these are very Central to even
this question of why do we need to keep
on extending the simple formula to get
at the same behavior
interesting interesting okay let's talk
a little bit about you said instruct but
we'll call it rlh Chef so yeah
um sort of reinforcement learning
fine-tuning to align with with human
values or references or whatever
um the alignment people talk about it
we're using it in all of our models what
do you mean in really high level terms
what does it do
yeah I actually have a grumpy take about
this I don't think it's that different
from just treating it as a supervised uh
fine-tuning problem uh I think what it
does is uh so it's really interesting
because I think what's going to emerge
uh probably given the piece of research
over the next half a year is just more
ablation showing the impact of the
quality of annotations versus the actual
optimization procedure so the
reinforcement learning part I don't see
is intrinsic to the gains that we made
but what has clearly produced a lot of
value is just having these really
comprehensive annotations and an
investment in just the type of
interactions that we would consider very
um
a very high caliber dialogue and so I
think that paired with the optimization
objective being RL for me my grumpy
takers it matters less I think you could
structure it uh along a few different
objectives including just supervised
fine-tuning and still achieve very
similar results given that you had a big
enough base of annotations fascinating I
mean do you see that in any way a
contradiction to you know we spoke about
Jan McCune and it's all in the data and
so on and there's there's this really
interesting kind of Continuum in the the
life cycle of machine learning models
starts with the data and then you have
like the all of the different inductive
biases in the model Randall's done some
interesting work kind of almost trying
to squeeze out the inductive bias of
data augmentations so in in a sense it's
almost like you're saying oh it is the
data that's really important it's not so
much the model is that something we
should aspire to
I do think it's primarily the data here
the optimization objective if you think
about it RL the way the what it actually
means uh it feels like window dressing
on this problem rather than like the the
core contribution of the set of
techniques uh much more important I
think has been having a rich set of
annotations which uh really Express both
the quality of human engagement and then
having some type of ranking system but
you know RL is just one way of doing
that right you can also do that by being
more selective about what you use as
your fine tuning data set and then
fine-tuning you can do it by process of
subset selection of audio Collective
prompts and you can also do it by
process of ranking in some way RL being
one possible way to do so I think people
gravitate toward maybe we should call it
shifting right and the data is Shifting
left left people gravitate towards
shifting right because they have this
rather fanciful idea of emergence and
lots of amazing thing things happen if
only we have this blank slate unified
approach to machine learning training
and what you're leaning towards is
almost recognizing and admitting the
complexity and what we need to do on the
data side
so it's a little bit more nuanced so yes
if you have a limited you know computer
and you can extend your model size as
much as possible you can throw a lot of
parameters of problem and treat it as a
uniform problem but I actually think we
just need to be better at sampling from
the underlying distribution that we want
to represent and in some ways this is a
core of machine learning overall this is
you know often our goal is for some
representative Downstream tasks we want
to have a distribution that we can
sample from that we can trade on and I'm
suggesting that we're going to
progressively as we get better at
sampling because right now we
essentially just do a comprehensive
sweep and end up with a lot of junk as
we get better sampling I think we can
gain a lot on the model efficiency side
interesting so two quick things on on
people have cited rlhf as the biggest
successive reinforcement learning which
to me is a damning indictment of
reinforcement learning I know but um I
did I did read I don't know whether you
saw there was an article on them less
wrong I'm not sure if you read it but it
was visualizing the um you know like the
the
um the probabilities of the next token
with rlh chef and without and what it
seems to do is kind of like it you can
you could I want to I want to ask you
whether you think it's robustifying or
the opposite but it makes it much more
likely that you would get a certain
trajectory because it kind of like
fattens the you know the probability
margins for certain tokens in respect of
certain prompts so do you think that's a
form of robustification or brutalization
oh that's fun I remember the article
what do you mean by robustification
versus simplification so they they say
that rlhf does a couple of things so
robustification in the sense of like you
know given you you can ask things in
slightly different ways and you'll get
the same answer and the answer will be
more aligned with human preferences so
you could argue that's a form of
robustification but people have said oh
the models are less creative they're
less kind of random and crazy than what
they were before and I'm not quite sure
using my machine learning lens whether
whether you could think of that as is
robustification
yeah I think that it so
I guess there's two questions here is
Ariel the only way to get that I would
argue no there's other ways that you
could achieve that one is by just subset
selection and spending more time and
annotation you probably implicitly end
up guiding certain preferences that are
more aligned with our own so it's not
clear RL is the trick here but let's say
okay let's take the premise as is and
say is that creating something more
robust or is it creating something more
brittle because it doesn't learn in
certain parts of the distribution you're
kind of up waiting certain parts of our
preferences or what we would like to
engage with
um
the problem which we have yet to solve
is adaptation right this is the core
thing so it's capturing our preferences
now and that's in some ways making the
model more robust because it's capturing
a a perspective of what we how we want
to engage but that's going to change the
same way that the long tail now is on
the long tail in the future and this is
one of the big open challenges for
researchers is how do you adapt one of
the most simplistic ways uh that we are
currently learning about the world is
that we have these Global updates and so
we essentially are training models that
are memorizing a distribution but as
soon as we introduce new data we
override everything and this Global
update is at the core of the issue as
well as uh this need to treat all data
equally these are really we don't have a
notion of adaptive capacity or
modularity and the this is one of the
biggest issues that our current models
grapple with because regardless of
whether this is making it more of us the
current distribution some ways it's
brittle right because we're not
exploring the boundaries or we're not
when when we have a different
distribution of set of preferences how
do we adapt the model itself I agree
that's a huge issue so
um language models are fascinating they
do what is basically a trivial objective
it might be a denoising water encoder or
Auto aggressive decoder but you're just
doing something basic and you get this
emergent you know stuff happening so you
can look at it in a different domain
it's not just a hash table anymore it's
doing something magic and then we can
discuss whether or not it actually
understands whether you can call a
language Model A type of knowledge store
or not because it's rather fanciful but
you can kind of say you know like when I
do web development you separate the
style and the structure and now I'm
separating the knowledge from the
presentation so I can say take this
Sarah hooker interview and present it as
if you know Leo Tolstoy wrote it right
and it's kind of like internalized them
knowledge so if you do believe that
there's a there's such a thing as a pure
representation of knowledge so that's
one thing but the second part of the
question is if you do believe that
there's a pure representation of
reasoning right because these things do
reason presumably you could rather than
using it the way we do now you could do
all of the stuff you're talking about so
it could have information that reflects
our values and you could use it as a
reasoning module on the top
yeah I think Ukraine is something
important which is that
the best evidence and support of what
you're saying the second point which is
can you use it as a form of reasoning is
just the effectiveness of few shot
prompting right because often you adapt
to it for entirely new tests there's no
gradient update framework and yet we're
inducing really
behavior that for many people was very
compelling and it was very you know
fulfilling the desired angle so that
would be the the strongest support of
the second point which is uh where it
having an understanding of huge colossal
data sets appears to be in party in this
ability to interpolate over High
dimensional spaces in a really
interesting way in which we don't appear
to need explicit gradient updates often
we can often induce it just by prompting
in certain ways the kind of part to that
is that prompting right now is like Tea
Leaf reading so like we have different
models and the same problems don't work
we have extremely intelligent trained
researchers who are kind of probing the
model like reading a horoscope this is
the kind of uh very brittle in many ways
and so one thing that we're we're
clearly not Gathering is a good
understanding of this High dimensional
space so even though to your second
point we're clearly creating a general
models which can be induced to produce
certain behaviors the mechanism is not
at all well grasped at this point and so
we kind of end up bumping into it often
and this is a fun open question to think
about can is there such a thing as a
general prompt that would work on many
different architectures or is it always
going to be really this probing of the
high dimensional space to induce certain
behaviors that we think are interesting
interesting okay so there's a couple of
ways of thinking about prompting or
speaking to a professor from Imperial
and he was kind of saying oh don't worry
prompt engineering will be a dead job
next year because the language models
will start to get it and then that's one
way of thinking about it but I'm
actually thinking no there's the The
Prompt is is important you know some
people think that embodiment is
important right
um it's almost like the language model
is embodied in the prompt There's
Something Magic In The Prompt I'm giving
it the cognitive priors I'm kind of
structuring how it fits this you know
it's almost like a an interpreter for a
program there's something very important
to happen in that but
do you think that as language models get
better the type of prompting we do will
converge or change or do you think that
it will always be a bit of the Wild West
I think that
if it Remains the wild west it is if it
remains so high variance like the
structure of the prompt matters the
template matters the model matters what
the data set was matters then it's hard
to know if what we're doing is not just
probing the decision boundary until we
find a configuration that works and
that's not science so my hope is we
converge to a better understanding of
how these high dimensional spaces are
formed and we can probe in a more
effective way it's also interesting to
think about like how does this variance
how is it impacted by things like scale
so as we get to much larger scales do we
see some type of stabilization and what
we what we see as the effectiveness of
problems and the ability to guide with
less work but right now for me prompt
engineering is less
a science and more it's really just a
probing role where you're using your
human decision boundary to understand
the model decision boundary by doing
enough configurations
and that needs to change if it's going
to be a scalable approach yes I quite
agree one one thing that I find
remarkable though about language models
is that even though they do have certain
computation limitations and even
linguistically that I mean that they've
mastered syntax nearly but there's no
semantics there's no well there's a
little bit of semantics there's no
pragmatics we're talking to Laura Roos
about implicature the other day so but
in spite of these limitations it's like
weirdly when we use them we can fill in
the gaps and it's still going to be a
transformative technology it works
remarkably well but but you know just
talking about the limitations I mean I
just mentioned a few and simple
grounding is another one people talk
about I mean like how do you weigh that
up
I think it's a really exciting
technology
so what you're talking about with
Laura's work uh so that was work uh I I
was also involved in that Laura was the
first door with this so she really
Champs
no Laura is incredible and she rightly
so she led that so it's really her I'm
so sorry I forgot no no no throw you
away but I think what's interesting is
that uh
we see this failure of these certain
types of behavior but those are really
hard behaviors to learn in general why I
think we're able to fill in the Gap is
that uh our language is very dense
communication format to begin with so to
be honest if two English speakers meet
uh they can have zero shared background
or references but still communicate with
complete eats right and so what are you
choosing a very dense representation
which is why I think uh we're so
effective at filling in gaps because
it's already communicating a lot even if
it's not perfect and this is something
why language is so interesting to to
think about but it's also why I think
it's an incomplete version of the
ability to navigate the world robustly
because the challenge is what you have
what how do you deal with much more
sparse less dense rewards indeed
before we close out is there anything
else that's top of mind that you'd like
to tell the mlst audience what you know
what what's exciting you at the moment I
am just delighted by leaving you in
prison this is so nice and I just want
to say thank you so much for uh
everything you do for the ml Community
because it's such a so-called seeing all
the interviews and uh just your coverage
of scientific Communication in general
so I feel very thank you I I really
appreciate Thanksgiving thank you so
much hopefully I didn't uh didn't uh
bore everyone too much with subtle
details but he was amazing we love we
love the details okay yeah we um we
absolutely embrace it and Sarah thank
you so much I really appreciate it so
much yeah happy holidays amazing